We Begin this hour with a look at the
future of how infrastructure repairs may
get done crews in Boston are working to
meet a Monday deadline to complete
Year's worth of repair to an aging rail
line shutting it down meant arranging an
army of buses rolling out temporary bike
lanes and trust me from experience
longer commutes Chris Van Cleave reports
after this Boston Subway car caught fire
on a bridge Massachusetts Transit Agency
shut down the busy orange line for a
month replace approximately 900 feet of
rail Federal Regulators had urged the
agency to speed up five years worth of
repairs with the baby schedule it's a
little hard to to stay stay right on
track with one-year-old Emerson in tow
the shutdown has doubled Lauren Gray's
commute with a t-second busiest line
shut down people coming to the stations
are now boarding buses used to be about
a 20-minute ride to get downtown now
it's closer to a 40-minute drive
the 11 Mile Orange Line links major
hospitals colleges and downtown offices
to Southwest Boston neighborhoods
carrying more than a hundred thousand
Riders daily it's disruptive I think I
have to be honest about that it's
disruptive to many people's lives Steve
POF Tech is mbta's general manager how
did it get this bad I think we've always
been in a position where we're balancing
trying to provide as much Service as
possible to our customers while
providing access for maintenance it's
not just Boston part of Washington DC's
Metro system shut down for months to
bring a new station online and complete
needed repairs and next summer
Cleveland's rapid system will see a
similar shutdown if we need to disrupt
the line for a month so that it works
well for the next 20 years you know
that's that's kind of the balance Mike
shipper co-authored the American Society
of civil engineers infrastructure report
card it gives the nation's mass transit
systems a d-minus do people need to
prepare for
some period of disruption in order for
things to get better especially a rail
line on the railroad there's no detour I
think you're going to see some more of
these the 2021 infrastructure Bill set
aside roughly 40 billion dollars for
Transit funding but the repair backlog
is estimated at 176 billion
Transportation secretary Pete
butterjudge what we're confronting right
now is not just one or two years of
deferred maintenance it is a lifetime of
under investment the goal is when the
orange line runs again it will be with
newer faster trains short-term pain
today with the hope of better commutes
tomorrow for CBS Saturday morning I'm
Chris Van Cleave in Boston